well nowadays I guess I get called up
quite far in advance saying would I like
to work on something and you say yes I'm
free I could do that and then because
generally if you're working a lot then
you don't really think about it until
it's much closer to the time so I
personally we might meet with the
director for a bit chat about the
project but then it kind of goes to the
back of your head if you're working on
something else and then you when you get
in there first thing I do is we start
talking first day we don't do any other
thing we don't do anything we just have
a chat about it and usually they have a
script but that's usually your work
fiction so it changes completely but as
long as you so that's when when I sort
of get deeply involved is when the first
day you start and then that way focus so
you know that's works
I think editing is all about interacting
with people mainly because I mean when
you get into an edit everybody knows you
can work the gear or they assume you can
so that's that's not what they're
looking for is somebody who will engage
in a way that is not just pushing
buttons I mean there are some some parts
of the industry that that's the case but
I think the the main thing that people
probably don't realize about anything is
people skills because if just working on
a project for six weeks a year you've
got to get on with a person there and
and know how to handle the situation and
I think that yeah that meant that maybe
is not so much so easy to teach and
people they realize that that's a big
big thing I think the main thing is and
i i i i don't necessarily i think it's
it's it's in you i think you've got to
have a very good idea about what the
story is on any project you're working
on even if it's a small children's item
like a blue blue peter item which is
what i used to do as well or a big big
documentary or i don't know if so much
about drama because it's all scripted
but in documentary certainly you have to
have an idea about what the story is and
how to tell the story and i don't think
that's that's necessary
I think people either have it or their
the or they they don't in a funny kind
of way and I think that's the kind of
thing that you really need to kind of
nail as an editor is that okay what's
the story how do you tell the story in a
clear way said that the narrative flows
and it and it's almost like you don't
notice the editing so I think that's
kind of really important working on Blue
Peter I think was probably the the thing
where I thought wow hey I was kind of
working on it and I was sitting there
and I used to watch it as a kid thinking
wow I'm working on Blue Peter amazing
and but they were so the whole team they
were so inclusive in back in the days at
the BBC when when it was a you know
there was still sort of teams around
there and they were very nurturing of of
people because they would have I used to
be an assistant film editor and at the
BBC you would you would go to sound
editing and then you would then choose
whether you wanted to stay in sound
editing or try and get the opportunity
to go into picture editing which you
could do in those days and Blue Peter
were very that very good at getting
people new people into the system and I
would say that was that was the biggest
sort of breakthrough for me oh yeah I am
a David Bowie fan it did help I also am
a big music fan rounded musician as well
and I think that helps actually whether
you're editing music documentary or any
documentary being musical knowing how to
pace things it's all about that it's all
about orchestrating but oh yeah I was a
big Bowie fan so really getting getting
the job was was pretty pretty amazing to
be honest there were hours of interviews
so you had basically the all the
interviews with the main people all his
band members from the New York a day
from his black star album and from the
album before at Tony Visconti of course
the producer and we had a very very good
archive researcher who found a lot of
material for us to use and of course
they shot on that one they shot all the
songs with the bands or key songs with
the bat
and so it was pretty amazing actually
hearing the band that played on the
record actually playing the track and
that when they gave us David Bowie's
team vocals
we were able to sort of construct a
version of the track with the band
playing live and put his vocals on there
which is kind of unique and was pretty
extraordinary actually pretty
extraordinary hearing him saying Glaser
Asst with no music very very poignant
actually it was a 90 minute program but
I first cut with something like three
and a half hours and you have this pull
this huge story and you can you can't
tell the whole story you have to choose
which moments to hone in on and make
them work with what's been shot and all
that sort of thing so yeah there was a
lot of material and there are a lot of
ways you can go and yes in the Edit
that's what you're doing with the
directory or you're you're finding out
okay what is essential and a what of the
channel want which is usually a lot of
hits but yeah so there was a lot of
material but you know you hold it down
you hold it down and that's it the
second the second half of the film is
all about the last album and so they
they had the dire the director of the
stage play and weaving that in with the
last album and making it kind of mean
something that was that was really quite
tricky to do but you know it's it's
quite moving really and that kind of the
words it's almost like he'd written the
album as some sort of you know I knew I
know I'm going to die and I'm gonna
leave everybody with this maybe he
didn't I died but if that was that that
was the kind of trickiest bit sort of
orchestrating the end to make it
poignant but not sort of more Kishore or
you know oh let's get strings in and
whatever so there yeah that was the
challenge but it really got that you
know it was it was it was great and
people you know we had a screening with
his band actually they were all in there
and they're all crying I thought blimey
that's done it
they don't say great editing and you
don't want them to really because you
shouldn't really notice it and and if
people come up and say that and and you
know oh you it's great that you know
you really Dunham's proud not me
personally but Francis and director and
everyone but and that's kind of what you
want to do really with anything you
don't want to kind of sort of don't make
some bowls that you want people to kind
of absorb stuff and get stuff from it so
there's always a subtext to what you do
and and that's very satisfying when that
comes across
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]